welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and you've all seen the spider-man no
way home trailers by now so you
definitely have seen all of those hot
purple cracks appearing all over the
statue of liberty yeah what the hell are
those things anyway well i think i know
what all that purple is however to
explain the purple we gotta go full
steve urkel and break down the secret
hidden science of the entire marvel
cinematic universe and this video is
brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business so
let's dive into it my nerd babies
because hopefully by the end of this
video you'll be able to see the mcu like
monica rambo do because it is truly a
spectrum of energies that represent
every aspect of the mcu like we straight
up talking cmbr baby because at its core
all of that purple around the statue of
liberty in spiderman no way home is the
purple of the power stone singularity in
the mcu this purple power stone energy
is actually a little something called
gamma radiation and which you may know
as the radiation that created the
incredible hulk however scientists know
this as essentially the strongest form
of energy in the universe like this
is so powerful that it's mainly just
found in the hottest objects in the
universe like you know neutron stars
your best friend's older sister and when
stars explode in a supernova and let me
tell you there is no supernova more
powerful than the big bang in the
context of the big bang all the purple
gamma energy is literally the energy of
everything in the universe like all of
it like every star every planet every
person on every planet everything that
will ever be said on those planets these
are all represented as purple gamma
energy within this unbelievably super
hot dense singularity that will become
the big bang like it's literally the
size of a proton a very hot proton
throwing it back but why do i say this
well it's because controlling purple
gamma energy is exactly what he who
remains was doing in loki because
remember how those purple and blue
energies of the sacred timeline were
orbiting the citadel at the end of time
after we zoomed into a supermassive
black hole well those purple energies
were the energies of everything that
will ever exist like all the energies of
the timelines and the reason why
everything that ever existed was
orbiting the citadel is because the
citadel is actually at the epicenter of
the supermassive black hole at the
center of the dying universe at the end
of time because the citadel is the
object with the most mass in the entire
universe so gravity is attracted to
there and he remains is able to harness
the citadel's gravity in order to
control the purple power stone
singularity along with the blue space
stone singularity with you know the
purple in the timeline to maintain the
sacred timeline but more on that blue
stuff later because that's another
aspect of reality
because the universe is on a constant
cycle of big bangs where the universe
expands and big crunches where all the
energy in the universe contracts into a
proton sized point a scientific theory
known as the big bounce and this cycle
is told by the ancient cree of morag on
the walls of the power stone orb room
temple because the way that these panels
are supposed to be viewed is flipped
horizontally you know like the collector
had it in his garage because these
panels tell the story about how death
once reigned in the dark world because
it was dark and inhospitable to life and
then the power of all things got hotter
and harder until eternity himself
triggers the big bang with his hammer
sending infinity's energies everywhere
and creating our world of light until
the consciousness of the mind stone can
form into an ultron vision being and
bring about the start of entropy to the
universe which essentially means the end
of all things that resist entropy
meaning life this is why ultron doesn't
like people very much until all the
energies of the universe are gone
returning the universe to darkness where
everything basically looks like
dormammu's dark dimension but with all
like the rainbow singularity lights in
the background because those are all the
singularities that dormammu ate
everything would just be goopy just like
really weird goop because there's no
there's no form there's no there's
nothing so it's that's why the dark
dimension looks like soup
and because of this the void in loki is
literally the mcu's interpretation of
what happens to matter and energy inside
of the black hole that forms at the end
of time and this is why renslayer
describes it as a void at the end of
time where every instance of existence
collides at the same point and
simply stops because it's a black hole
and all of these loki's inside the void
are literally inside of this final black
hole trying to avoid having their life
forces broken down by the
personification of the destructive power
of the black hole eliath himself a life
is essentially the weaponized
destructive darkness of the biggest
black hole in the universe and this is
why eliath and all the hungry hungry
hippos of the mcu like act of the
harkness the dweller in darkness and
dermamu all have these glowing purple
energies like they ate so much energy
that they have entered the highest
energy frequency state possible the
gamma frequency but anyways the point of
all this is the significance of crossing
the threshold in the loki finale is that
king allowed the black hole to cross the
gravity threshold like the black hole
literally ran out of to suck on on
the black hole's event horizon and
because of this kang basically lost the
use of gravity to maintain the flow of
the everything energies of the universe
so what we're basically seeing here at
the end of loki when we cross the
threshold is basically the start of the
next big bang from the perspective of
inside of the supermassive black hole
like we're basically inside of the big
bang and when enough of these purple and
blue timeline energies intersect and
cross over into each other incursion
style this is when all the gamma energy
kang was hoarding will be unleashed and
the next big bang that kang was
effectively delaying by you know making
the sacred timeline will start and also
why if you slow down the big bang
footage the big bang energies are purple
at the moment of explosion because
purple is the everything energy
singularity and because of this this
could be why peter quills he's his mom
when holding the power stone and
potentially by the kings of wakanda can
travel to the ancestral plane because
both the power stone and somehow the
heart-shaped herb of wakanda allows
their nervous system to briefly tap into
the purple everything energy frequency
of the cosmos because of course when
people die our bodies just get recycled
back into the everything energy of the
universe for the next big bang i mean
according to the big balance theory
anyway so what we could be seeing above
the statue of liberty in far from home
are the purple everything energies of
the raimi and webb universes and all the
you know other sony universes included
in this movie crossing over into our own
and this is why peter is referred to as
chasing ghosts because these purple
energies leaked out and reformed into
all of his enemies the sinister six like
they're basically the ghost energies of
the sony universes that's it but that is
just the purple gamma power stone aspect
of our reality what about the other five
other infinity stone aspects of our
reality well with the gem explosion of
the big bang came with it all other
singularities the orange the blue the
green and the yellow as we can find on
the mcu doomsday clock on the walls of
morag which tells the story of the light
of the universe from the big bang until
the mind stone through ultron vision and
the scarlet witch can bring about the
entropy of all energies to return the
universe to darkness once again
basically ultron and the scarlet witch
were meant to end everything but notice
how i didn't say red energies before
well it's because red actually came
before the purple before the birth of
light in our universe and since nothing
is the opposite of everything the red
reality stone energies are on the
opposite end of the electromagnetic
spectrum like the opposite end from the
purple gamma rays meaning that these red
energies are composed of nothing but
weak radio waves wanda vision radio
waves and this is because all our
universe was was this red goopy formless
nothingness of the ether as we learned
about in thor the dark world and in this
nothingness this dark dimension part of
our universe the dark elves were as
supreme as the asgardians are in the mcu
now and they ruled over all the dark
universe aliens like the asgardians
ruled over all the light universe aliens
aliens that would eventually get upset
and team up with thanos to try to remove
as many light beings from the universe
as possible which is why thanos's crew
is called the black orders because they
want the universe to return to blackness
the blackness of the red chaos nothing
singularity and also all those weird
monsters from that doctor strange what
if episode were probably from this dark
time in the universe as well like gnomes
dragons demons mephisto maybe i'll
probably live in this dark time lots of
folks are starting their own business
and if you're one of those people or
want to be one of those people you need
a great website squarespace is an
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence for your business
squarespace lets you present members
only gated content connect your social
media accounts present video content and
all the other cool features to give you
a super cool super functional website
for your hobby or your business
squarespace will even sell you a url
which is super cool collect the emails
of interested folks and send custom
newsletters to keep them up to date on
what you're doing and all the cool new
business stuff that you're up to so head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com new rockstars for 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain and we thank squarespace for
sponsoring this video but anyways now we
got all that purple out of the way let's
talk about the mysterious orange soul
stone singularity now because what is
the soul stone in the mcu anyway well
from what i can tell the soul stone is
the singularity of evolution and
survival in the mcu but more
specifically it is the singularity of a
little something called negenthropy
which is the opposite of entropy which
is why eternity is on the opposite of
entropy in the moral panel if entropy is
the tendency of all the energy in the
universe to break down into disorder
then neg entropy is the tenacity of
living beings to rage against the
inevitable breaking down of our bodies
into useless heat energy like it's
essentially what we do every time we eat
we are fighting against entropy survival
is negentropy and it's also the same
frequency the same light that comes from
the sun of mcu earth because the cell
stone is basically the soul stone s-o-l
which means sun
nice play on words marvel and this is
the singularity that the eternals the
sovereign the extremist program shangshi
janet van dyne the nova corps the dragon
scaled warriors of tallow captain
america's vita rays inside of his
transformation chamber and the wizards
of kamatage and waverly place and every
single human on mcu earth are all about
and it's a singularity that a lot of
beings out there really want like you
know the dweller and darkmoon center
mama good singularity to have because
this is the singularity of our sun and
the singularity that will likely be
responsible for the rise of mutants down
the line because it is essentially just
evolution energy as jenna van dyken says
in ant-man and the wasp and hey speaking
of the sovereign there's probably a
little something you probably didn't
notice about their home planet y'all
because the sovereign don't live on a
planet at all i think the sovereign are
the light elves of the mcu that live on
six dyson spheres which are completely
theoretical man-made spheres meant to
harness the powers of stars which is why
there are six anulex battery generators
on the platforms that the guardians
fight on in the beginning of guardians 2
and the sovereign used the evolution
energy of their orange soul singularity
sons to facilitate their evolution this
is why the sovereign are gold and why
adam warlock will essentially be a
living soul singularity being which
would make sense given how much of a tie
he has to the soul stone in the comics
now let us talk about the blue space
tone energy frequency because blue is
actually quite a big deal because it is
the dark energy of the mcu now if you
don't know what dark energy is in real
life it's essentially the invisible
force in the universe that is causing
our universe to expand at a rapid pace
and the galaxies that neighbor us to
sort of just push away from us more and
more every day dark energy is the
singularity of expansion and like
propulsion and because of this it is
extremely powerful and versatile stuff
so versatile in fact that shield started
the joint dark energy mission facility
for the sole purposes of trying to
harness the dark energy of the tesseract
it was the main focus of howard stark's
entire life work after all and also the
very same element that he left for tony
to discover in iron man 2. it's all
coming together folks and hey do you
want to know what that secret element is
by the way uh it's vibranium like it was
originally called in the iron man 2
novelization before marvel retconned it
and i think the reason why they read
conda in case they wanted to i don't
know send a glowing blue dark energy
vibranium mound to wakanda in a future
black panther movie that's right my
beautiful nerd babies vibranium is dark
energy which is why tony was able to use
it as a power source for killmonger's
anime murder machines sword was able to
stimulate the vibranium in white
vision's body to act as a sustainable
blue power source and why mcu iron
hearts will probably be called iron
heart in the first place because she
will learn in wakanda forever that the
vibranium metals ability to be converted
into the same power source of tony's new
element but now that you understand
about dark and soul energy you can kind
of understand captain marvel's powers
more and why she glows orange when she
discovers her power towards like the
third act of the film because when she
gets more confidence in herself and
stands up to the supreme intelligence
she unlocks her terran soul singularity
powers and uses it in combination with
her tesseract dark energy powers to
activate her flight and make her even
stronger like she's basically a living
fusion nexus of two singularities yes
captain marvel is a living nexus of two
singularities much like wanda became the
nexus between the chaos and mind stone
singularities when she destroyed
vision's stone that is the exact moment
wanda became the scarlet witch she could
not do that before vision stone was
destroyed she's using both chaos energy
and the mind stones atomic energy but
anyways let's talk about the green time
stone next gang because this is my
personal favorite just because of how
wild it all actually is because the time
stone is actually a gravity stone
because when doctor strange uses the
time stone he's just manipulating the
gravity around him to manipulate time
because time works differently depending
on the level of gravity around you and
this is the secret of the air bending
tylo warriors like they're not
manipulating air at all they're all just
manipulating gravity because tallow is
actually sitting on a massive green time
stone that both the tallow warriors and
the great protector tap into to fight
the green energy frequency of the mcu is
gravity and once you understand that you
will begin to understand the secrets of
tal lobe like talo is essentially one
big time stone from the bamboo maze to
the weird gravity wormhole cave covered
in time stone shards and even the very
necklaces that shengshi and his sister
wear are gravity manipulating time
stones which is why xiongchi will be
able to make his soul singularity 10
rings levitate outside of the time stone
area of tallow since he doesn't use dark
energy like his dad did which is like
propulsion energy he has to make the
rings float via gravity and hell even
chung chi's mom's original name for the
longest time in all the promo material
for chongqi was zhang li until they
changed it to yingli because zhang li in
chinese means
gravity kevin feige decided to change it
because he was like oh no that's two
that's too close you're gonna you're
gonna give up the store you don't want
powerful people know it's gravity yet i
found out kevin i found out but hey do
you know what also means gravity i'm
cagliostro cagliostro is not a person
cagliostro is gravity like the books of
cagliostro are the books of gravity with
the eye of agamotto probably in
reference to the green eyes of the great
protector agamoto the dragon i think the
dragon zagamoto that's what i think and
this is why obeng the librarian says
this when doctor strange is looking for
cagliostro in episode 4 of what if where
can i find cagliostro well
maybe here maybe there
maybe nowhere obang was talking about
gravity because cagliostro is gravity
and finally we have the mind stone which
is i suspect the sentient atomic power
of our light universe that is trying to
get the universe to become dark again
remember when thor had that vision of
the infinity stones in avengers 2 if you
look at that cosmic cloud you can see a
brain inside of that nebula this is the
mind stone and the reason why the
mindset has been such a troublemaker in
the mcu is because the mind stone is
entropy the entropy is supposed to
destroy all hope of life like thor says
a whirlpool that sucks in all hope of
life and at its center is that because
of this the mind stone made ultron and
the scarlet witch to bring about the end
of light and start the next big crunch
however after wanda became a nexus being
after the energies of the mind stone
exploded in wakanda into her body she
gained the ability to create atoms and
manipulate electricity with mine stone
energy onto a layer of ether chaos radio
energy as the scarlet witch that's
essentially how her powers work she
makes a layer of reality and then uses
the mind stone to sort of just
manipulate the atoms of things and just
write things how she wants them that's
what gives wanda her reality warping
powers and why she didn't have it before
she exploded the mind stone but that is
the marvel life cycle of light in a
nutshell it starts off with darkness big
bang and then ultron in wanda try to
just turn off the lights and return the
universe to one of darkness but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird and you know
basically expound more on this theory
because i'm definitely going to be
talking about all of this stuff in a lot
more detail on my twitter so please
please if you have any questions follow
me on twitter and i will elaborate
because this is a lot follow me on
twitter so you can get the full story
but more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet and please hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload video
i love you guys so much and i'll see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
you